tell me about your role in the film I
play Graham's partner David Sherlock in
the film obviously David knew Graham
intimately I can't claim the same thing
I'm also pity really I wish I'd known
brand but I didn't but it's a wonderful
role and very happy to do it you know
about the pythons and how big a fan were
you before you actually took on this
project you know I remember when I was
it when I was a wee lad
I had a python book the one with a
keyhole in the front and you can see a
woman's breasts through it and that was
my first Python experience or a
titillating of course and so I knew
about the pythons to me they represented
horniness and illicit sex I came from as
young obviously now I mean they're
probably the greatest comedic team of
all time I mean I just can't be touched
I mean a wonderful body of work and yeah
I mean I privileged to be part of this
and part of Graham's story albeit a
complete lie of course but yeah I'm very
happy to be part of it did you learn
about crime that you didn't know before
taking on the role that you now think
wow that's quite incredible and yeah I
learn a lot actually I liked the fact
that you went to Oxford that he was
qualified as a doctor you know his whole
kind of running the gamut of you know
his struggles the homosexuality and
coming out and being on the booze and
all that stuff that he went through in
his life and you know and and and and
the extremely touching footage at the
end with other pythons at his funeral so
and and you know it was a really really
intimate looking to you know the other
side of the camera not just the funny
stuff that went on but the other stuff
that affected his life and so yeah I
learned a lot I think a lot of people
will learn a lot more about
then they've probably know did he speak
to David at all before you stuck on his
role in the film no I didn't know I
haven't haven't met him actually I think
I think I'm meeting tonight and they
probably like oh my god you did my voice
you're fired
too late too late David I've done it now
a friend of mine is a guy called under
Jack I mean he didn't sound he did all
the sample if they only actually stars
in the film as well he has a role to
place himself me and he called me
happens so we come in and do a voice
because he knew David and I think he
thought I had a similar Tambor in my
voice and went and did it and and yeah
and I think terry gilliam heard it and
said it's that David Sherlock but no no
it's my mate Philip but he sounds like
him so obviously it was he and Ray did
well in picking me to do the role but I
was very lucky to get out it's quite a
compliment isn't it you miss he plays it
back yeah and I think it's one of those
things that you just think I remember
going in and doing it it was very kind
of like off the cuff I was telling some
other guys down there is all kind of bit
impromptu and off-the-cuff and you kind
of think yeah it's a little thing I'm
going to do and I didn't realize it
would turn out to be this this huge film
with all these 14 animation companies
involved in it in a really kind of
different approach to filmmaking and
animation and and something that I think
is a very special project yeah have you
seen the film yet and how do you feel
that your your role fits into it I have
I have seen the film fighting with the
barriers here tripped me up
yeah now I have seen the I've seen the
film once before and yeah I think it's a
wonderful wonderful piece and if I've
got I've got a couple of bits in it I'm
not just David I do some other voices as
well some secret ones I do a drunken
Mouse which was great are they a Scots
party guest I do a Kiwi a Kiwi Airport
announcer and an American bellboy so I
really run the gamut of the accents
they're all rubbish
bill stand they'll sound Irish but you
know never mind it's too late now
you